bonjour je m'appelle capcom à dabou
bonjour messieurs un canard la piteuse
et à pouilly fuissé deux canards à la
picardie merci montrait jean tigana
revial ans chez moi il ya du bon grain à
s'éteindre et picard il a trouvé seul le
chemin
ce n'est pas un traquenard tu trouveras
même des copains farine crème fraîche et
mars seront au bout de temps destin
alors lâche le couteau que tient dans sa
main
jb - venus qui vais me couper les coen
assassin je vais me faire couper les
gones face à ce métal vous avez été
lauréat de la poêle d'or pur
la recette du canard à la picardie ne
vous avez créé qu'est ce que c'est qu'un
canal la picardie et bien c'est une
recette que nous avons mis au point pour
cette un mélange si vous voulez du
canard laqué le canard chinois que tout
le monde connaît bien et qui est un
canard entre le canard traditionnel cuit
au four et ce canard laqué alors nous en
avons sorti le canard à la picardie aux
roms que nous allons voir ensemble
comment le constituer voilà il est déjà
découpé en quatre morceaux soul avons
découpé en quatre morceaux il nous
allons passer maintenant à la farine de
façon de le faire vite soleil et qui ne
s'attachent pas qu'ils soient bien dorés
voilà cette belle simple
alors là nous allons bel et bien laissé
le temps de doré aux pièces de canard
nous allons ensuite le flambeau rome de
façon de le déclasser promettent un bon
rhum de préférence bien sûr voilà cette
fois notre canard et rissoler nous
allons passer dans un deuxième temps
dans une cocotte auquel là nous allons
le faire cuire le tranquillement 52
minutes environ nous pouvons d'ailleurs
ajouté ce fonds à cette sauce là nous
allons oui au vin blanc 1 2008 environ
ce n'est pas obligatoire d'ailleurs de
mettre du muscadet on peut mettre un
autre vin blanc sec de bonne qualité
bien sûr vous préparez donc déjà une
sauce là nous allons préparer une sauce
alors maintenant cette sauce nous allons
la préparer ou était ce qui tout comme
ingrédient est bien comme ingrédients là
il nous faut simplement deux jaunes
d'oeuf 250 g de crème de crème fraîche
temps de préférence là aussi j'avais
oublié de vous dire qu'on peut ajouter
cette fois le canard il nous donnera du
moins à notre fonds voilà
je crois qu'on a à peu près compte en
1950 g c'est bien sûr quelque chose que
un peu moins un peu plus vous préparez
590 ou canard cuit pendant que le canard
puis nous allons la jupe et un sceptre
composition pour bien la base de façon
d'éviter trouveront l'otage voilà là
nous allons laisser cuire tranquillement
on peut d'ailleurs il ya deux façons
peut l'ajouter aussi en dernière minute
il est un résultat à peu près similaire
707 pour l'instant dernière minute là il
nous reste maintenant le temps
d'attendre de 50 minutes environ pour
pour que ce canard soit lui est présenté
avec cette chose que nous allons taper
en dernière minute nous allons passer
cette sauce au chinois
nous allons lancer ils ont qu un chinois
un chinois et bien c'est tout bonnement
cet appareil c'est une passoire puis à
porter l'appellation de chinois parce
que elle est la forme de du chapeau de
chinois
oui oui oui
non mais
alors les 50 minutes sont écoulées et
bien je crois que oui nous allons
regarder effectivement nous notre canard
et comme vous pouvez le remarquer puis
très bien hors isolé auparavant nous
allons le dresser sur ce plat de
dégustation voilà qui est fait nous
allons maintenant le napper de cette
sauce onctueuse sont rodés à g ration
toutefois voilà nous allons soupoudré
pardon nous allons saupoudrer d'amandes
voilà donc bernard villaret près de
service aux clients
il est chaud servi servi à point voilà
notre canard est prêt à partir
[Musique]